meanwhile close to the city where the
fake chemical attack has allegedly been
filmed terrorist factions are still
active we received the following images
from one such place in hammer province
where civilians are constantly being
targeted by militants
we heard the roar and then there was
dust everywhere
I grabbed my daughters trying to cover
them with my body who lost an Verna I
went out to find him and saw him in the
corridor there was a pool of blood
coming from his head sawed off the Zima
camión and several days ago a rocket
landed in front of my house my mum wife
and three children died I remember how I
called home of no one picked up
the alum some people died young lady and
little girl and two teenagers also died
okay well we can talk now to an
independent journalist and writer IVA
Bartlet who's in Damascus at the moment
but has actually been to mojado the
footage we saw there
you're very welcome Eva thanks for
coming on this afternoon we know you've
been to that village can you just tell
us what you found when you were there
yes when I went there I talked to the
civil sorry the National Defense Forces
and they spoke at length about how the
village has been pummeled by missiles
from terrorists in the outskirts of the
heart a just a few kilometers away and
it's been on a daily basis over the past
many years and they've said you know
they've been suffering nobody is talking
about it and they're looking forward to
the liberation of it Lib because it will
ease their suffering it will it will
mean the cessation of these terrorist
attacks on it Lib the NDF commander told
me that 117 civilians in this small town
have been killed by such attacks over
the years and fifty two additional
Syrian soldiers have been killed and of
course then on September 7th there was a
major attack terrorists fired nine grad
missiles I was told six of which which
were fitted with cluster munitions and
they fired them at this village killing
11 people and injuring 20 some of whom
were critically injured so these are the
kind of things that the media which is
busy talking about corporate media which
is busy talking about it live are
completely negating happening on a daily
basis in Mohammed day and there's a
nearby village which my colleague
Vanessa Bailey went to and I'm it's
called scale via in on September 9th I
believe that was the latest attack by
terrorist actions in which they fired
according to myth sabili 10 grad
missiles on this village so it's a
similar situation where these civilians
have been suffering - the silence of the
international corporate media sure and I
know while you were there you spoke to
people didn't you residents there let's
listen to an interview you did with a
father who'd lost his family in a
terrorist shelley
honey I'm dismissing Salinas ready buddy
hey Kate chimp lady I should tell you
hey buddy
she
obviously a very traumatic time for him
um even while you were there did you get
a sense of how often these shelling
attacks happen I noticed that he was
saying they happen continuously but is
it every day every other day can you or
is it pretty random
I would say it's more than pretty random
but maybe not every day on a near daily
basis and I talked to one man he was a
volunteer in a committee that works to
help families that have martyrs or
injured people in the families and he
was saying you know some days they
received more than 70 shells so
certainly it is a disastrous situation
and that man who I interviewed shadi
Yousef Shehadeh he lost three hits three
young children his wife and his mother
in this terrorist attack and it wasn't
the first time by the way that his house
was hit it was targeted twice before and
his neighborhood in general has been
targeted ten times by such attacks what
the residents say there about the
looming battle end for Eid lib
they what they say and what Syrians have
spoken with around the country on
previous visits and currently says they
want a restoration of all of Syria to
peace and they want an end to the
terrorism that's been plaguing them
whether enid lib or as we saw formerly
in eastern Bhutto or before that in
Aleppo and it's their right to live in
peace and it's also their right and the
Syrian that the government of Syria's
right to fight such terrorism because
we're not talking about the mythical
moderate rebels we're talking about
al-qaeda we're talking about Aurora Shan
and Jason Lee Salaam and these are
terrorists that have been torturing
civilians and executing civilians
wherever they happen to occupy so most
people I've met know everybody I've met
is looking forward to the restoration of
full peace and security in Italy the
argument we hear often aver is that you
know Italy is a province of 3 million
people and there are quote only 10 to
15,000 terrorists there there could be a
huge humanitarian disaster if there is a
full onslaught from the government how
do residents feel there are they afraid
of the human cost that could occur
if you mean residents in Italy by I
can't speak for them but I'd like to
note that in each case where there's
been a pending liberation of an area
occupied by the terrorists I just
mentioned we hear such such cries such
crocodile tears from humanitarian
agencies and Western leaders in Western
media and usually the numbers are highly
inflated
I cannot say personally the number of
civilians in it lib but I will recall I
will remind people that when eastern
Aleppo was being liberated even the
United Nations was saying 300,000
civilians in eastern Aleppo and in the
end it was half that number or less so
that that's one point I'd note that even
that the Pope has joined in this this
frenzy of calls about humanitarian
crisis and he may well be neutral but
I'm concerned that his wording didn't
mention the terrace factions in Midland
and it's the timing of his wording
particularly his call for the use of
tools of diplomacy
well the Syrian and Russian governments
have been using tools of diplomacy if
you'll recall they've opened
humanitarian corridors they've offered
amnesty and reconciliation to terrorists
who will wait lay down their weapons but
on the contrary it's these factions
within they live that are saying we will
kill any terrorists well militants
rebels I think whatever they want to
call them we will kill them if they
participate in amnesty and
reconciliation
so clearly yes there is a desire for a
peaceful resolution to this and the
Syrian Russian governments have been
offering tools for such a peaceful
resolution and the other thing I'd like
to note is just I can't attest to the
numbers of different terrorist factions
in it live at the moment but we must
recall that with all the previous
reconciliations most of those who
decided not to take em masti and go back
to their peaceful lives in Syria and
instead decided to join the foreign
terrorists they went to it live so I I
believe there's a highly greater number
than simply ten thousand of these
terrorists in Midland what do you lose
view sorry either on the Russian
government at the moment and the Syrian
government fearing a potential false
flag chemical attack in Italy
I think their their fears are well based
we've had a number of Western officials
declaring and basically giving the nod
to al-qaeda and other groups that if
there is a chemical attack they will
retaliate with force
so basically terror groups in India are
being told we have your back you can
stage a false flag attack and then we're
going to attack Syria illegally as
they've done before in many occasions
but I think also the the note that the
Russian reconciliation center in Syria
and the Russian military have seen for
example militants transferring barrels
and canisters of chlorine to areas of it
live where it's believed a false flag
attack will occur I think that's one
important point and the Russian military
is also seeing the white helmets
involved in the delivery and the other
thing we have to recall is that children
have been kidnapped from areas of Italy
and Aleppo and countryside and again
I'll refer to my colleague Vanessa
Bailey because she was just in an
Eastern in the area that was liberated
and she was speaking with the family
who's whose son was kidnapped about a
year ago and this family is very
concerned that their son will be used
along with other kidnapped children and
adults in such a false-flag staged video
and she was told that in the last year
over 600 adults and children have been
kidnapped so I think there's grounds to
be very concerned that the white helmets
which are known to be not the neutral
volunteers they may brand themselves as
and the terrorists that they cohabitate
with will staged another false flag
chemical attack mmm they even look good
to talk to you were going to have to
leave it there but that was Eva Bartlett
an independent journalist in Damascus
thank you
you